of this city of endless opportunity
ready to get your cherry popped
come on see like any other just bigger I
just hit another city legends are born
here in a chewy brownie your cos Dex
pulling the strings
stop that put cease and we lose them but
we are they just don't know it yet but
if you got the cojones and you know how
to use them you could do damn near
anything unless you catch it boy
even then you go out with a bang right
you know you can make heaps mores
motivational speaker yo mr. V a pleasure
so what's the game Dex we need to come
out in one piece how about we go over
the plan there's this prototype ten
biochip to be precise Josh the plant
guessing it belongs to a court era
saucer
some heavy-hitters you can blackmail me
[ __ ]
how is have a war first woman be after
life cut king baby goes without saying
we do this on the hush
I deal in nobody not a one
sounds simple enough
[Music]
we're gonna be danger don't you worry
more hack with bulletproof what the [ __ ]
just happened in there it stopped do you
like [ __ ] me happy now Jackie [ __ ]
[Music]
Jax what the [ __ ]
game risky fee and you who are you [ __ ]